For four months from September 19, 1870 to
January 28, 1871, the Prussian Army laid siege
to the city of Paris, as part of the Franco-Prussian
War.
Prior to having all supply lines cut off,
the French Ministry of Agriculture furiously
worked to gather as much food and fuel as
it could, and at the beginning, “livestock
blanket[ed] the Bois de Boulogne park on the
edge of Paris.”
Apparently insufficient, within less than
a month, the Parisians began butchering the
horses, with the meat used as you would expect
and even the blood collected “for the purposes
of making puddings.”
By the end of the siege, approximately 65,000
horses were killed and eaten.
Within another month, by November 12, 1870,
butchered dogs and cats began to appear for
sale at the market alongside trays full of
dead rats and pigeons.
The former pets sold for between 20 and 40
cents per pound, while a nice, fat rat could
go for 50.
As Christmas approached, most of Paris’
restaurants and cafés were forced to close,
although a few of its top eateries continued
serving, albeit with a markedly different
menu.
And as traditional meats were becoming increasingly
scarce, the formerly impossible became the
actual – when M. Deboos of the Boucherie
Anglaise (English Butcher) purchased a pair
of zoo elephants, named Castor and Pollux,
for 27,000 francs.
The enormous animals were killed with explosive,
steel tipped bullets fired at close range,
chopped up and sold, with the trunks being
the most desirable and selling for 40-45 francs
per pound, and other parts between 10 and
14.
Prized by the fine dining establishments,
for its Christmas feat, the Voisin served
elephant soup, and for New Year’s Day, Peter’s
Restaurant offered filet d’éléphant, sauce
Madère.
The elephants weren’t the only zoo animals
featured on these menus, as the Voison also
served kangaroo and antelope, while Peter’s
also served peacock.
In addition, rats, mules, donkeys, dogs and
cats were also transformed by their chefs
into roasts, chops, cutlets and ragouts.
Ultimately most of the animals in the zoo
were eaten, with the voracious Parisians sparing
only the monkeys, lions, tigers and hippos.
It is thought that the monkeys were left because
of their close resemblance to humans, but
it isn’t clear why the lions, tigers, and
hippos escaped the menu.
In any event, the siege was ended by a 23-night
bombardment campaign in January, in which
the Prussians lobbed 12,000 shells into the
city, killing and wounding around 400 people.
The Franco-Prussian War officially ended with
the Treaty of Frankfurt on May 10, 1871.